so we are going to talk spoilers and
netflix knows that this will not air
until
after the season has dropped so don't
you worry the deal is the deal
um well played
away thank you thank you very much
show-offs
follow at the very end of season one
we see kiragan emerging from the fold
with his niechi voya right behind him
ben is read the book is it
to say that hell have no fury like a
darkling scorned
i think he's been scorned on so many
fronts mal's tried to kill him for sure
and there's just tried to kill him he's
taken umbrage with caz who's got one up
on him
jasper has definitely shot his right
hand man over the side of a boat his
mother's betrayed him
jenny's portraying him i think he feels
pretty hard dumped zoya's betrayed him
i think he's probably quite lucky he's a
long list of vendettas and now that he
is sort of like all-powerful
even more and he's lost his home in his
army i think it'd be interesting to see
how he prioritizes that list of fury i'm
excited to see him kind of
stick into that yeah and how do we fight
pure smoke
like dark shadows you get another
amplifier i'll see you guys on the boat
in season two
cool good girl now the work begins
if we get a second season how much your
minds are wrapped around it i need
nikolai so badly what is the status on
on his potential casting
as far as i know we haven't gotten the
thumbs up yet for
season two so we're hopeful and
certainly we have a lot of
plans we would love to see come to
fruition and i would
love to see i'd love to see sturm on i'd
love to see nikolai
i know a lot of people are clamoring to
see wylan so
uh we have big plans but we'll get to
see if we
have a chance to bring them to the
screen so no prussia
do you feel like with the crows already
being part of the storyline
is there still room for some of those
other beloved characters to still come
in like tulia and tamar
for sure absolutely i mean they're gonna
be a lot of mouths to feed but
i'm up to it i'm up for it as well i
cannot wait to see what happens and i
hope you guys like boats because
that's nice
y'all are just gonna be filming on boats
and i'm very excited to see though
what you've done with the first
amplifier is so gruesome
what the fetter could look like that's
gonna be really cool we have been
dreaming and imagining in these worlds
for a long time now
and it's hard not to think about all the
things we could do and
and i i just keep saying i'm greedy now
i'm so greedy like
you know i i felt so humble and like oh
just if anything gets made and the
chance to see this and now i'm like do
it all
do all of them so i would love for that
to happen but
you know it's really up to the viewers
we can let this one go
sounds like a trap anyway a trap would
sound easy this is something else
i'm already looking ahead to season two
there's so much in six of crows
that we didn't get to explore amita what
would you like to see from anez
if we do get a second season that's such
a great question
i think eric heiser and leigh bardugo
did such
a bloody brilliant job of merging the
two different stories and
finding this new content for everyone to
hopefully enjoy
so i fully trust them to kind of i don't
know somehow
do even better because they always
always do i would love to see
the first time kaz and inej meet
because for me that's such a beautiful
moment and in the book
that moment has stayed with me
throughout this whole time
and the feelings that created in me
especially when i was concerned as in
edge
so personally for me that would be
wonderful and just introducing
six of crows to the three of us right
now and just kind of
getting our gang together but i'm sure
the writers
i i fully trust them to bang out
something
incredible freddie how about you what
would you like to see for cars i'd love
to tease some more of the back story and
you know although i'd be putting myself
out of work i'd love to see young caz
and his brother you know i'd love to see
exactly tiny cats but like amita said i
had so many preconceptions coming in
well i've read the books and it has to
be this there has to be this in there
and like and so i totally understand all
of the fans being really excited to see
it kind of
you know i want to see this and i want
to see this move but actually what the
writers have come up with
so far surpassed my expectations that
i'm kind of
leaving it to them you know we get to do
more i just let them get on with it
because it was so much better than what
i could have
dreamt up kit what do you want to see
for jasper more mischief
more more kind of cheeky shenanigans
more kind of characters to play with i
mean
you know as far as for the six of crows
readers out there of all those capri
characters i'm i'm the one that hasn't
got my
my other half yet so obviously i'd love
to i'd love to meet weiner but while
income was the whole host of characters
as well
though his whole like dynasty has to be
introduced and
i'd also love to get to work with an
actor who'd be playing my dad
because that would be that would be
really special as well i think you stick
with us
everybody gets what they want